[Music]
hi everybody i'm talking today with
dennis prager who you might know from
prageru he's a national syndicated radio
talk show host heard on some 300
stations across america and around the
world i'm also talking with adam corolla
who's best known as a comedian actor
radio personality television host and
new york times best-selling author well
back to dennis he is also the co-founder
and president of prager university the
largest conservative internet video site
in the world with over a billion views
per year 65 percent of which are by
people under 35 years he's a new york
times bestselling author as well of 10
books
a biblical scholar with expertise in
biblical hebrew the third volume of his
five volume commentary on the torah the
rational bible will be published in the
summer of 2021 it's become the
best-selling bible commentary in the
country
back to adam currently hosts the adam
corolla show which holds the guinness
book of world records for most
downloaded podcast
we're going to talk today about the
movie that these two gentlemen were
deeply involved in a documentary no safe
spaces and the
problems it's encountered in
distribution and
well we're going to range out from there
into issues of free speech and perhaps
beyond that as well so welcome guys
thanks very much for
for talking with me today dennis maybe
you want to start do you want to talk a
little bit about
well about craig or you and also maybe
about the movie no safe spaces about the
documentary
well one relationship of prageru and the
movie
that adam and i are in
is the suppression of free speech
i testified at the u.s senate two years
ago
on what they were doing to prageru
videos
it may be the single funniest thing on
youtube
except for anything adam corolla does
and i'm not being cute adam carl
is perhaps the funniest human being in
the english language he might even be
the funniest in any language i but i my
ability to assess that is limited
well i'm number four in urdu
that's very impressive i was wondering
exists that's the pakistani life
well you want to crack the top five you
better be familiar with
that's great well you see what i mean
jordan
i have a big problem when i appear on
stage with adam and that is i'm totally
happy if he talks the whole time all i
do is then do you know that
this is not even answering your question
but i just want to say this you'll get a
kick out of it so adam and i have gone
around the country doing uh doing events
on stage
and uh he he may not even know this uh
but there are times during the event
well i will say to myself dennis they're
also paying you so you should speak
i feel a moral obligation to talk but
selfishly i just rather laugh because we
all need laughter and anyway his his
insights are just deep anyway uh so what
i said was the funniest thing on youtube
was this
i i was at a senate subcommittee on the
suppression of free speech
uh testifying about what's happening to
prageru where uh hundreds of our videos
are placed on the restricted list
meaning if you have a filter against
pornography and violence you actually
can't see the video so one of them was
in fact one one that i had given i only
give one tenth of the videos ninety
percent of other people but i i have
given a number of videos on the ten
commandments for example and so senator
ted cruz asked the representative of
google
why did you surp
people could see this on youtube it is
still there
why did you uh why did you put mr
prager's uh talk on on uh
on the ten commandments on on the
restricted list and the man looked at
senator cruz and said
because it mentions murder
and i remember i remember humming the
twilight zone theme because i i felt i
had entered an alternate universe so
what do you think the reason was dennis
i mean obviously look that's got to be a
bit of a pr nightmare for google to do
something like that so it smacks of a
certain degree of incompetence to begin
with and i i like to hypothesize
incompetence before malevolence
so so why do you think it was censored
that specifically and then why with
regards to is it reasonable to call
what's happening with prageru censorship
and why do you think it's happening
because well i'll tell you the the i'll
answer the last one first
and this will help
you realize that i think there's more
malevolence than incompetence
there is never an instance in the
history of the world and this is my
field of study since i was in graduate
school of columbia that's why i studied
russian was to read pravda and visit the
soviet union on multiple occasions and
other and other communist countries
there is no instance
in world history
that is since the russian revolution of
the left gaining power and not
suppressing speech liberals offer free
speech conservatives are for free speech
the left has never been for free speech
okay so let me ask you a clarifying
question there all right because
you know i come i'm a canadian and
i suppose along with the scandinavian
countries were tilted a fair degree to
the left compared to the us and so i
mean freedom of speech is
in reasonable shape in our countries
those countries that i mentioned and so
when you talk about the left
tell me more specifically what you mean
and how you would define that particular
state
because you're not talking about the
democrats per se i can't imagine or
perhaps you are the democrats used to be
i was a democrat the democrats used to
be liberal the democrats when i was a
kid in the 70s nazis real nazis not
people they just call nazis real nazis
with swastikas
demonstrated in in skokie illinois
because a lot of jews lived there
especially holocaust survivors it was a
particularly vicious act
and jewish groups the aclu liberal
groups the democratic party all defended
their right
because in america anybody could say
anything except yelp fire in a crowded
theater that is no longer the position
you you look you're why did you why did
you get in trouble
and you're right you're i've wondered
about that for a long time okay so
no
well i'm
if you're wondering i'm not you uh you
said something the left didn't like that
you were not going to be told by the
government what pronoun you will use
okay so let me out let me ask you
another question so when i look at
political surveys i see that
there's a very limited number of people
on the right that you could describe as
extremists and there's a very limited
number of
people on the left who appear to support
the more extremist leftist propositions
and so i do believe that in some sense
it's more difficult for people on the
left to draw distinctions between
acceptable leftist ideas than it is for
people on the right i mean on the right
you draw the line with claims of racial
superiority on the left there's there's
obviously trouble brewing on the extreme
but defining exactly where it is and
drawing a border around it is seems to
me a relatively complex task and well
you asked me why i got in trouble i mean
i got in trouble because i said well i'm
not sure where to draw the line but that
particular law compelling speech with
its implicit theory of identity that's
gone too far as far as i'm concerned but
you know the fact that that caused so
much trouble i think is indication of
the fact that it's difficult to draw
the line and so well i'd be interested
in both your comments about that
well i i think you're on to something
with the extreme part of the right
wing party is pretty definable
and i think most reasonable people agree
that the farthest right
um you know
jews shooting laser beams into the into
the sky and shooting down satellites or
whatever
crazy stuff comes out of
q and on or sort of far right stuff
racial things of that nature
um
i think we can all agree that that's
pretty definable
and that most people on the right
will not cross that border
uh and william buckley helped with that
wouldn't you say
i would but on the left
i feel like there's a much greater sense
of well we don't agree with aoc but
we're not going to say anything about it
or we're not going to define it or or
the squad so there's a much more you
know i live in california most everyone
i work in hollywood everyone's on the
left
their thing is sort of like we don't
like what gavin newsom is doing
but he's still our guy
and you know we'll go well that's part
that's part of this difficulty with
drawing borders like i've had
conversations with democrats about the
idea of equity for example which is a
no-go zone as far as i'm concerned
because of its connotations of equality
of outcome but they insist generally
speaking that most of the people who are
using the term equity are really using
it as a proxy for equality of
opportunity they're lying to you they're
lying
they're flat out lying either to
themselves or to you and and both are
dangerous
equity why if the if the word equity
means equality why don't they use the
word equality well that's right that's
my argument doesn't mean equality
well what do you think it means exactly
i know what it means it means equality
of outcome just exactly what you implied
it meant that's okay so it means
why do you think that's so toxic
because it means standards don't matter
it means results matter is there equity
in the nba
how many jews are in the nba
how how many uh how many japanese are in
the nba
there's no there's no equity in the nba
and there shouldn't be i only want the
best basketball players and i want the
best pilots and i want the best
physicists and i want the best uh do you
know that they they are dropping uh the
the i follow music i conduct
periodically i'm very into music
so uh the new york times has advocated
the dropping of the blind auditions for
the new york philharmonic
no longer shall you choose the best
violinist or oboist you choose based on
the color of the violinist or oboist
that's equity
okay so you have you're making two
arguments about equity one is that it
flies in the face of a rank order of
value with regards to
competence and it's predicated on
uh distribution of equality by immutable
characteristics like race and sex and
gender perhaps sexual preference all
these things that become part of the
cultural context
and that's equity and their the word is
being used because it doesn't mean
equality of opportunity which means a
playing field that's open to everyone
who strives forward and who are then
chosen on the basis of their merit and
how would you define merit just out of
curiosity
well i think i'm sorry dennis but i
think
i think the blind you know
it's really hard to
quantify certain things like who is the
best oboist it's it's it's difficult but
that's why you put the curtain up
and you decide and you have experts
listen you have experts listen it
doesn't mean they're right it just means
the only thing they're factoring in is
the ability or the perceived ability of
the oboist on the other side of the
curtain
and once you pull that curtain down you
sort of bring everything into question
okay so so you know if you're trying to
hire someone in the u.s the laws are set
up this way and and i know these laws
quite well
so if you want to hire someone you're
bound by law first of all to do an
analysis of the job requirements so you
have to make a list of what competence
means in that particular context so
that's merit as defined by that job then
you have to have to use the most
reliable and valid test
that's legally available that's to to to
do this election or you can be
or you're liable under the appropriate
employment law so merit has this very
specific definition it's it's sort of
within occupations so you define it
within an occupation and then you have
to use a selection technique that is
that assesses for that and that should
be blind to immutable characteristics
like race etc and i mean that's how the
law was set up for years and now we see
this situation where this is restorative
justice that's the doctrine
is that what we're seeing
why do you have a problem with that
exactly
well i'll i'll give you an example
in my mind
um you know dennis brought up sports um
i try to think why as human beings are
we so attracted to sports like everyone
loves sports but why does everyone love
sports why
is the ratings for the oscars plummeting
every year in the ratings for the super
bowl going up every year you know if you
just looked at a chart of the super bowl
starting in 1970 and the oscars starting
in 1970s 70 the oscars i think out rated
the super bowl but at a certain point
the oscars have you know less than 10
million and the super bowl is always you
know 40 50 million so
what is that as human beings what are we
responding to well what we're responding
to
is when we watch the super bowl
we believe
that the best players are on the field
regardless of whether the entire defense
of side of the ball
is black or asian there's never or
anything there's there's never been an
instance of the owner's son
starting on the defense or the coach's
son
starting on the defense now it doesn't
mean
these are it doesn't mean there's not a
12th guy who's on the bench who is
actually better but it means in the
coach's eye
these are the 11 best players to put out
on the defensive side of the ball and
the offensive side of the ball and we
never question it
when you then watch the oscars and you
see a lot of the diversity and a lot of
the forced diversity you think to
yourself are these really the best seven
or eight films of the year or
are we trying to conjugate some way
to open it up for things that are better
or different i should say than just the
best film and once you start down that
path i argue it's a very slippery slope
we tune out we lose interest what's the
big beef on the on the oscars best films
every year it's like i didn't see half
these things and where they were they
really the best film and then i saw two
of them and i didn't like them so you
don't think we trust the selection
process so i wanted to answer your
question you said why do we like sports
so much and that'll lead me to another
question that maybe i can direct to you
so i think dennis will find this
interesting maybe he'll agree maybe he
won't but
the word sin is derived from the greek
word hamartia which means to miss the
mark and so it's an archery term
and you know people are very very goal
directed
and what you see in sports is
the assemblance of teams of
excellence competing and cooperating
because they're playing the same game so
that's the cooperation to hit the target
and every time someone excellent hits
the target it's it inspires awe in the
audience and that's why everybody leaps
up sort of not even of their own accord
right they're possessed by the spirit of
the game
and so there's something that's very
very deep going on in a sports spectacle
because we're all participating in the
celebration of the team effort to to
facilitate the ability of the individual
to attain the goal
and that's that runs through sports it's
dramatized in a way that's not
rationally criticizable and your point
is if that's gerrymandered then people
won't appreciate it anymore but here's
the question i have for you why do you
think that the the meritocracy of sport
is so widely accepted and and not a
subject of of public attack when there
is a public assault on the idea of merit
in almost every other domain
why does sports get a get a pass so to
speak
i believe in sports we would all
realize the absurdity
if we tried to
mess around with the meritocracy of it
if you said
there's not been enough jewish
heavyweights in the last 30 years
we need to get a jewish heavyweight and
put them out there with tyson fury or
whoever the current heavyweight belt
holder is i think we would all
understand
the sort of bizarre nature of that and
we all sort of inherently understand it
wouldn't it wouldn't work or back to
dennis's
example if we took you know why do you
think it's more obvious to us i think
you might be right but i can't figure
out exactly why we we seem to accept i
mean
people suffer for for the
distinctiveness and athletic ability i
mean it's a trope of many many american
films you know there's the the boy who
would like to make the football team but
can't and it's painful and so we accept
that that pain is real and it exists but
we don't use that to justify an assault
on the meritocracy of sport i just can't
figure out why it's so self-evident you
say it is but dennis you have any ideas
about that well
because it's more objective than
subjective
if you hit uh 40 home runs
you're you're a great player we don't
have 40 home runs in in almost any other
area of life
so
uh so you think it's a measurement issue
yes it is a measurement issue that's
exactly right stats are the are the
fans are crazy best baseball fans can
tell you the batting average of the
first baseman on the detroit tigers 12
years ago
this is what they live for stats but
there were no stats in much of life back
to my overweight right so so well so
that also means that the people who are
criticizing our society for its for its
power base say rather than its merit
base
they're partly led to that conclusion by
the fact that the stats of life are not
nearly as obvious as the stats in sports
i would argue sorry for cutting you off
dennis but i i would argue
that in this particular case
stats are on the other side so they go
delta airlines has less than 14
african american pilots
delta airlines employs less than six
percent female pilots and less than one
percent transgender so if you think
about the stats
we do love stats but they get used
against us on the other side when
they're constantly talking about you
know police reform or
the fire department is in a mostly
hispanic
neighborhood but yet the fire department
doesn't represent the constituency of
the of the group that it serves you know
because it's only 13 latino they
they do love stats but they love them
from a different side of the equation
right but exactly but those are not
stats of excellence those are stats of
of what jordan calls immutable
characteristics right the stacks are
easily measurable
but yes that's what i was pointing out
about sports but i believe that other
stuff is measurable too i i believe that
it is that
unless
unless one enters the world of the
absurd which we have entered
beethoven is greater
than uh anybody composing music today
uh is greater for that matter than any
non-german composer
who ever lived uh
the greatest composers were
overwhelmingly austrian and german
so
why do i care i only care about there
being great music i'm a jew i know
wagner was a rank anti-semite and
hitler's hero and i love wagner's music
i don't give i don't care when i listen
to his music
when i hear the ring or you know any of
his other operas the the man was a
genius so uh i don't assess
assessed by that at the university of
pennsylvania they took down the english
department english department and an ivy
league university took down
shakespeare's picture because he was a
white european male and they put up a a
non-white lesbian
uh instead
not because of measurable excellence but
because of immutable characteristics
yeah well i guess adam's point is that
it's easy for people to default into
easily measurable
statistics when the alternative
measurement systems are somewhat obscure
it's harder to rank order musicians by
their quality i mean you could look at
how often their pieces are played by
major orchestras for example but you
know you could make a case that that's a
consequence of systemic prejudice as
well
so you have these stats
that
that signal immutable group membership
that are pretty comprehensible and they
lead people astray because they can't
evaluate the broader context of
excellence so easily i mean we have to
look for cognitive biases right when
we're trying to explain things as as i
said before reaching for malevolence
even though i'm perfectly willing to
reach for malevolence when i think it's
there
so
let's let's move back to no safety
if you don't think it's malevolent
what do you think is the is the
justifiable reason for taking down
shakespeare at an english department
well that that that might be envy and
resentment that could well be i mean i
talked to somebody interesting recently
paul rossi who is the new york teacher
who stood up against the political
correct incursion into the private
school at grace church i it was
and he talked about the attraction that
post-modern theory held for him when he
was an undergraduate and he said he
really wanted to be a creative writer
but he really didn't have the talent for
it and so
it was kind of annoying for him in some
sense to be exposed to all these great
authors because it represented the
pinnacle that he couldn't scale and then
when he was introduced to postmodern
theory which critiqued all of these
great authors as perhaps not great at
all let's say it satisfied some vengeful
and resentful resentful element of him i
mean he grew out of that and was able to
talk about it but i think that that's i
think he made us a fair case and as i
said i'm willing to identify malevolence
but for me it's a last it's a last reach
you know i look for cognitive biases and
that sort of thing first and
i mean i think too you look at so many
people that are attracted to radical
left ideas for example they're
predominantly young people not only but
predominantly and
you know they're looking for a
causal
myth
let's say they're looking for a myth and
a causal explanation and it's fed to
them it's not a surprise that they
devour it some of that's malevolence
because it gives them a target for their
resentment and their anger but some of
it's just ignorance they haven't been
taught a more comprehensive viewpoint i
mean you're trying to do that at least
to some degree on prageru and you're
having some success with young people as
well which is quite interesting
right
i don't i don't charge the young people
with malevolence i charge the the people
teaching them with malevolence people
who teach the 1612
narrative
are malevolent they loathe the united
states and this is their way
of of uh destroying our society by by
teaching young people that it was
founded in order to preserve slavery
it's a gargantuan lie and again i i just
need to say this again
uh i
uh
to the dismay of many of my fellow
conservatives because i read comments on
my pieces on the internet i'm interested
in comments
and uh many
think i'm a fool
or no they don't say naive
for distinguishing between liberals and
leftists
but it's a huge distinction and the only
way for the salvation of the west is to
teach liberals that the left is their
enemy and not the right
that is that is the key task of all of
us
liberalism has nothing in common with
leftism and it has everything in common
with conservatism so what do you what do
you think that liberalism and
conservatism have in common where's the
common ground speech let's begin with
free speech the subject of this
i i also think uh in intellectual
honesty you know a couple of guys
in this town who i know
who are
i wouldn't call them leftists but i call
them democrats
um
and probably progressive who are also
liberal in a true sense are bill maher
and attorney mark gargos
uh they're both vote democrat
but when subjects come up they're
intellectually honest and you end up
agreeing on quite a few things
with these folks just because they're
they're having intellectual honesty
so
you know they
they they may be on the left when it
comes to some social issues or maybe
some border issues but
they do understand governmental
overreach and tyranny and oppression and
things like that especially as it
pertains to covet
and they have an intellectual honesty a
perfect intellectual honesty
subject
is israel versus palestine
if you're on the left you have to side
with palestine if you're liberal
you can vote democrat
be liberal and intellectually understand
that israel's not the problem in that
region and that's a pretty good
yardstick i would say to measure
liberal
versus leftists um israel
okay so dennis you're drawing the
distinction between liberals and
leftists in that sense the leftist that
you're having the trouble with so here's
a question for you so
if the liberals and the conservatives uh
have common ground
um
and
they have the right behind them so to
speak i mean the correct let's say the
honesty
and the whole weight of i wouldn't just
say western civilization but the central
civilizational tendency because i think
it's a mistake to identify this
reflexively with the west
but in any case
why is the why has the left become so
attractive what are the liberals and
conservatives doing wrong with regards
to their the education of young people
or to the marketing of their ideas
i mean
what's going on what's happened here all
right you're right that's a very fair
question
uh
i i did a research on the five embassies
that showed that the black lives matter
uh banner
uh the u.s embassies around the world
five that i that were identified one of
them was the united kingdom the largest
u.s embassy in the world
and i looked up in each case to who the
ambassador was i was curious who would
put up what i consider a hate a hate uh
group banner
in front of the uh american embassy
and it turns out fascinatingly that the
uh uk
uh we don't have an ambassador to the uk
we have a charge a duffer the head of
the embassy in the uk is a woman
and in the wikipedia entry it noted in
passing
that her mother
uh is on the board of the new york civil
liberties union and i mentioned that on
my radio show and i said
you know leftists really do tend to uh
perpetuate themselves better than we do
the number of conservative parents with
kids are on the left is far greater than
the number of leftist parents with kids
on the right
but the reason is obvious the reason is
they have everything
they have kindergarten they have
elementary school high school college
university postgraduate the media sports
late night television there is nothing
that we have except independent voices
like the three of us here and thank god
others in addition to us that's the
reason if the schools were all
conservative then the leftist parents
would have a very difficult time keeping
their kids a leftist it's this is not
funny
you know when i talk to to
left-leaning people in the united states
they feel that they're
on the defensive they feel that the
right has more power they point more to
state governments for example
and it does seem to me as an outsider
because i'm an outsider told of this
that one of the things that does
characterize the united states maybe
more than any other country in the
entire west perhaps not because there
are there are there are countries that
might be an exception is that
there is
a reasonably decent balance of power
between the right and the left if you if
you consider the totality of the system
i mean you have democrat power federally
but at a
i'll make with all of the people who say
that to you the following deal we'll
give you state governments you give us
elementary schools high schools and and
graduate schools and universities and uh
we'll make that let's make that you get
we'll take the new york times make it
conservative you can have all the state
governments you want i think it's such a
they live in in a deluded
image of themselves and the world if
that's what they believe oh you have
state governments we have the new york
times and cnn and the washington post
and colombia and yale and harvard and
stanford but you have state governments
please
so okay so that's interesting i mean you
you believe that these educational
institutions well you also included the
new york times and i'm not going to
dignify the new york times by calling it
an educational institute but you believe
that the educational institutions from
kindergarten all the way up through the
universities have the signal power in in
in in the american culture you think
that's a reasonable claim
i'm not disputing it i'm asking you if
that's what you believe
how could it not be that's where your
kids spend most of their
waking hours
well i mean it's you know go ahead
asking sorry i think jordan's asking is
it
a foregone conclusion that all the
universities and high schools and junior
highs are left leaning 99 yet yeah well
i i'd like i mean it's certainly it's
it's certainly been something that's
very disturbing to me i think the
objective evidence supports the
supposition that they're overwhelmingly
left-leaning and it certainly seems to
me that these critical ideas
the idea sent especially that
the the structure of the west is
predicated on the arbitrary expression
of power i think that's the most
fundamental pathological claim that
emanates from the west is that power is
the fundamental human motivation and
that our functional institutions are
essentially predicated on the arbitrary
expression of power i always think that
people who say that are confessing more
than they are accusing
because most of the people i've seen
who claim that seem to be perfectly
willing to use power as their
predominant mode of operation in the
world i guess i would also ask you
why is it that the story that
power is the fundamental animating
spirit of civilization let's say but
we'll say western civilization just to
keep it narrower why do you think that
story has such resonance
especially given well let's leave it at
that
i mean i have thoughts that also uh
pertain to the schools because
to me and then i'll i'll answer your
question but i
i'm i'm curious if what are the origins
of of schools and and why or why to the
left and not toward the right
so if you've got a group
and we've all done it where they go we
want you to speak to a group of
commercial
property builders you know these guys do
tenant improvement work and they do
commercial work and they're real estate
developers and engineers and architects
and builders
um
you'd know who you were talking to
i mean you know what their politics were
just a small example
uh in my spare time i like to race cars
all the guys who show up to the track
they basically have the same politics
and the reason they have the same
politics is because they live in a world
where they have to prepare their car
then they have to go out and execute it
and they have to drive their car and
it's a real meritocracy because
someone's going to get the checkered
flag and someone's going to come in last
and they have a sort of collective
mindset just like you know
most people who run a small business
have a sort of mindset they want less
regulation and lower taxes and breaks
and they tend to be republicans so what
are we finding on school campuses well
school who who is attracted to be a
professor who's attracted to be a school
teacher it really is a little slice of
socialism
here in the united states we're
basically saying you get a job you don't
get paid that much but you can never get
fired you'll get tenure it'll be
an easy life you'll never really have to
hang your neck out or your shingle out
there's no chance you're going to go
bankrupt there's no chance you're going
to be at the top and there's no chance
you're going to be at the bottom you'll
just sort of have a job forever so
those are the people who are attracted
to the profession nobody i know who's an
entrepreneur is attracted to be a school
teacher maybe later on after they've
sold their third company and have you
know more money than they can
then they can count they want to go back
in and teach them business classes or
something like that but you're
attracting
people who have a little bit of a
socialist
bent or leaning
just from the beginning versus folks who
want to go into the military or folks
who want to start their own small
business now
how long would it take
for those people
to start
indoctrinating your kids i don't want to
use a word that's that strong but it's
essentially
getting them to sort of think the way
you think i use this example
what if all teachers
were vegetarians
they said vegetarian how long before
your kid came home for thanksgiving and
said meat was murder it would be
impossible
for them not to sort of
have that
through osmosis or or beyond
sort of
push that agenda to your kids so
it's gonna go this way it has to go this
way because
the campuses are inhabited with people
who naturally
lean toward that and lean away from the
entrepreneurial spirit then
once the kids graduate they end up at
the new york times and now the new york
times is the new york times so
this shall continue in my in my opinion
because
it's
at its fiber that's what it's based on
i was talking to a group of canadian
dissident academics yesterday and one of
them janice fiamingo she's a former
feminist former english professor and
who
uh abandoned her leftist ideology a
number of years ago and has become a
very vocal and articulate critic of
leftist activism in academia
she pointed out something quite
interesting that's a bit different in
terms of its causal pathway let's say in
the universities you know back in the
60s women's studies was established and
women's studies
putatively was about women but perhaps
it was mostly about critique of
male dominance and so then perhaps it
was particularly about critique of
dominance and that idea got a toe hold
in the universities and
started out with women's studies but
spread to the whole grievance studies
industry and that's more or less taken
over the administration and
you know
pushed its tentacles out into the rest
of the faculties as well literature
english literature in particular the
humanities more generally the social
sciences to some degree and now
increasingly biology and physics it's
not so much a temperamental argument you
know as a structural argument that
we we we set up an institution that was
based on
what would you say resentment and hatred
at least to some degree
and then that generalized across the
disciplines
well
yes i agree fully with that i just want
to go back to the question you posed
about power
you made
you offered a throwaway line which i
thought was uh utterly correct and
insightful
that when the left talks about power
it's confession
uh rather than accusation alone that is
and here is a massive disadvantage
to people who are conservative
uh
i'll use myself as an example only
because i speak for many in this way
i have been asked to run for office all
of my public life
and i actually once did file to run for
senator of california and then i woke up
uh a sober
and and i don't even drink
uh but it was uh
it was a moment of non-sobriety
in any event uh i've always said on the
radio
i am infinitely more interested in
influence than power
i have no interest in having power how
distinguished them
how to distinguish them yeah yes because
i can't i can only influencing you is
not the same as having power over you i
cannot tell you
uh uh that you uh must keep your your
store closed and go out of business
because of a virus
i have i have no desire to have that
power and i resent those who do and if
you used your influence how would that
did differ from the expression of power
well power is coercive influence is not
everybody well let's expound on that a
little bit because this does get to this
question see i'm staggered by the idea
that a very large minority of the
population now appears to believe that
the guiding spirit of human civilization
is the arbitrary expression of power
rather than something like influence or
or cooperation or negotiations the left
cannot influence that's why they don't
debate us i have had the number of
leftists who have accepted invitations
to my radio show in 35 years can be
counted on the digits of your hands and
feet
i i even had howard zinn came on to my
show i i have i've extended to i have
said i will pay a thousand dollars to
any new york times columnist other than
brett stevens who comes on anyway uh to
come on to my to come on to my show
that i will travel anywhere to to debate
them
uh but it doesn't happen i'll pay ten
thousand dollars to have any black
leader debate larry elder they'll never
do it
they don't debate
they because they're crappy at influence
they're great at power
and that's what they know
power
and so they would say you know they
would say well
you call it influence because that suits
your moral that puts you in the moral
high ground but you're a privileged
person you're white you have a huge uh
you have access to a huge media empire
you can say what you want and you can
talk to millions of people
you call that influence but we call it
power and part of it is because you
didn't deserve what you have and that's
a consequence of your privilege and
i mean this isn't something i believe
but so how do you explain oprah winfrey
uh i
i'm sorry did i are we still on well
because jordan had to switch between the
person that was trying to punch holes in
your point and then back to himself
so i don't think jordan knew how to
reply in terms of should i reply as
myself or the naysayer that it's uh well
i could yeah i couldn't come up with an
argument from the perspective i was
trying to you know put forward i mean i
think oprah winfrey was successful
because she's credible and and
remarkable that's that's my hypothesis
but
okay so so she's a token how about that
she's a token yes she's a token so uh
it's the the the number of black
influencers in our societies don lemon
the token i i mean it's it becomes an
absurdity after a certain period of time
anyway that's it's a non-sequitur
whether or not i i have an advantage
being white
is a non-sequitur to the to the issue of
i don't want power over other people we
conservatives want to be left alone
the left does not want to be left alone
and they don't want to leave you alone i
want to leave you alone except for the
most obvious things you can't murder you
can't steal etc but by and large we want
to leave others alone i know they will
raise abortion but if they don't
acknowledge that abortion is at least a
moral issue
and and there is an issue whether it
should be banned i fully acknowledge
that but there is no issue about whether
it is a moral issue they deny that it's
even a moral issue that that the human
fetus is uh is is worth less literally
worth less than a hamster there are laws
protecting hamsters there are no laws
protecting the human fetus i mean it's
so but but other than that they can't
come up we don't we don't want to
intervene in your life like they want to
intervene in ours that is why the masks
issue became one a political you would
think it's just science by the way if we
did follow the science the new england
journal of medicine last year which
nobody bothers quoting
did say that they were essentially
worthless outdoors and they weren't
worth much indoors either then they went
and said oh of course we weren't saying
people shouldn't do it but they didn't
take away their original
case they want
the mask issue is in large measure what
conservatives think it is power not
science
well i think we
fortunately
in a in a bizarre way
uh just lived through this experiment
called covid19
you pretty much could divide the country
into red states and blue states so if
you just sort of looked at it as a
as an experiment let's just
see if we can remove the politics
of sorts from it and even the disease
itself or any knowledge we have of it of
personal people who died or people got
it or whatever it is if you it's if you
just sort of looked at it more as a
metaphor
you take the country
you take the blue states and how they
reacted
dennis and i are in california or you
could have gretchen whitmer
in michigan um she was telling the blue
states were telling you don't go boating
uh california arrested a guy who was
paddle boarding alone in the pacific
ocean i mean the footage is
breathtaking it's literally a guy
on a surfboard with a paddle standing
alone nobody within
yards maybe miles of him and a boat
pulls up and they literally arrest the
guy
on the beach which obviously is much
more dangerous than whatever it is he
was doing alone but if you just said
let's just do a little mine let's have a
little experiment
this disease showed up how did the how
did the right leaning states act and how
did the left-leaning states act well
that's all you need to know i mean it
doesn't need to be a virus it's the left
snapped into action and started doing
what they wanted to do which is control
california's gavin newsom and mayor
garcetti and all they all jumped into
control because
that's what they wanted to do
it's almost like
we all had those friends do you guys
know if there's any data on death rates
between red and left and red and blue
states any reliable data because that'd
be quite interesting yeah there is
reliable data and uh you may recall that
when texas dropped all of its uh
mandates uh the president of the united
states said it was neanderthal thinking
and there was absolutely no spike in
cases or deaths in texas nobody talks
about it now because the president said
something incredibly stupid but
typically of the left they dismissed all
uh all freedom-loving policies with
regard to this particular disease we
should have followed what sweden did i
never thought in my life that i would
use sweden as my moral model in western
society but the world is not fully
predictable
but i think we have our answer
as to which side wants more control
because the outcome ended up being the
same
or
in in many cases better for the for the
red states
so it had really nothing to do with
science and it really didn't have
anything to do with data it's just the
left saw it as an opportunity to do what
they want to do what they're inclined to
do which is control
and the right is dennis the argument
that dennis made tried
some things but they were trying to
refrain from the sort of totalitarianity
of of
of what the left was doing which is
which is total control so it was a
little experiment we just went through
it we got the results
and i i think it's it's it's pretty
self-evident at this point
it is
all right so let's go back to the movie
if you don't mind we we took a large
detour and it was worthwhile but you you
tell us about tell us about no safe
spaces first and then tell us about you
know your your attempts to get it
distributed or the attempts to get it
distributed
well i'll i'll start with the the movie
and then dennis will go on to the uh
attempts to be distributed um oh i
actually wanted it to reverse
okay
well that's fine
either way
uh
you know dennis and i are very different
we have very different backgrounds but
we do have
common sense in common and i have found
more and more and i'm assuming you guys
feel the same way which is just finding
someone with common sense seems to trump
all the other characteristics that we're
constantly talking about about you know
where what region you're born in or who
your team is or what color your skin is
uh dennis and i always had common sense
in common
and we struck up a great friendship
we've done many speaking engagements
we've always had a great time in each
other's company
and so when the producers came to us
with this idea
uh i immediately jumped at it just
because it selfishly seemed like we
could spend a lot of time
together talking about a subject that
we're both pretty passionate about which
is free speech and
since the time we made this movie i i i
i feel like things have gotten much
worse i think the
movie was
a bit ahead of its time in terms of
what it is the subject matter and now i
feel like in just the three or four
years since we started
this free speech issue
has gone into overdrive go ahead dennis
yeah
a word on the movie and then a word on
the distribution
i i've said from the beginning and i um
i i'm neither arrogant nor humble i i i
i just pretty much try to see myself in
life objectively
uh and i so i have said uh
this is a great movie
and it's not a great movie because i'm
in it might be a great movie because
adam is in it but
the truth is it's a great movie and adam
and i happen to be the quote-unquote
stars but that's not the point of the
movie
uh i have watched this about five times
i have the attention span of a child
and so for something to keep me riveted
five times uh speaks
immensely about it it is it is it truly
is an important movie it's more
important today even than when it was
made
about free speech and it's gotten movies
within the movies and anyway people
should see it
i'd like to point out too just
just as an advertisement of sorts
there's a canadian equivalent to that
movie called better left unsaid that has
faced the same sort of distribution
problems that you guys have faced and it
focuses on issues that are more germane
to canada although also relevant to the
us and so
um well
they deserve a note they did they
deserve to mention so i'm glad you
pointed out i happen to think that
things are worse in canada than in the
us
uh but uh that's an interesting
discussion for either another time or
later on uh today so what was your
impetus for making i'm in the movement
of everything you spoke about the
distribution yes yes netflix refused to
distribute it
uh uh to to stream it which is
incredible given how popular the movie
is
okay so make a case for that like why
okay so netflix should have been
incentivized as as far as you're
concerned by the fact that the movie was
economically successful and there are
other streaming agencies too online that
are fairly powerful so amazon etc
have you had any interest from any of
the streaming agencies yes well it's
interesting i don't know the i'll look
up the amazon question i know that the
walmart doesn't sell it in its stores
they they have the same thing
uh all you need really in in at netflix
or walmart or any of these is one or two
people who are awoke
uh to tell uh you know we can't do this
we're gonna get a bad name uh and and
then you know what what is it to netflix
not to listen to somebody says oh dennis
prager
we know we know for a fact that it was
my name that was the trigger
which is an interesting thing
which i
one day would be fascinating to discuss
because whenever my name is is raised as
this bugaboo
i always say well can you say anything
in 35 years of broadcasting 10 books
literally 1 000 columns on the internet
plus tens of thousands of hours of of
the radio recorded
say one thing that i have ever said
that strikes you as extreme
and so there's never an example this
literally never the new york times did a
piece on me they couldn't find one
sentence
they made up something in fact they said
prager suggested
and i always tell people if they don't
say said
don't believe the line
suggested is the new york times not what
i said and then they had no quotes but
anyway
i've had the same experience dennis you
know i know
of course you have i know that
i can't find a thing you've ever said
that is an ennobling
i i love your work i wrote the prep i
wrote the introduction to your biography
i had uh i had this experience as well
and then i have another thought which is
uh i got into a lot of trouble and i got
out of favor with critics because
um
it was widely
said that adam corolla said women
weren't funny
now this is perfect and you guys have
experienced a version of this
i did an interview years ago and the
person said at the end who's funnier men
or women
and i said well i think men are i think
it's based on them trying to have sex
essentially so they had to exercise that
muscle a little bit
but
i know many female comedians that are
funnier than anybody any guy ever went
to high school with
that then turned into adam carlos said
women weren't funny
and then they just ran with it
and that's up there
with that well look it's it's pretty
credible what you say because my sense
is is that
there's been a couple of things i've
said
that have been blown up in the press you
know and they were
exaggerations of the sort that you're
describing taken out of context
i think that in the current climate if
you've ever said anything reprehensible
on public record
that you will be slaughtered for it and
so if you haven't been slaughtered for
it the probability that you haven't said
anything reprehensible is pretty damn
high because
people are combing over the the
utterances of people like you trying to
find a smoking pistol i don't know if
you can comb over things to find a
smoking pistol but
i i will tell you another institution
that's sort of been ruined and i think
jordan was sort of
getting to it and it sort of gets back
to the oboe or the cello player for the
new york philharmonic
how do you say that one film is
definitely definitively better than the
other film you know it is subjective and
or objective and and or subjective sorry
but
you are
you know so a lot of the answers is sort
of
make a better film and you'll get in
you'll get onto netflix or make a better
film and you'll get into the sundance
film festival so
i've had five films all turned down from
the
from the sundance film festival
now
jordan the way jordan's mind is working
is you're thinking
well how but how do you know i mean they
couldn't no i'm thinking why don't you
organize your own damn conservatives
but the the
the
the academic in you is thinking how do
we define that and and as we spoke about
earlier when the guy hits 40 home runs
in a season that's definable
and uh when the guy drains 14
three-pointers in a playoff game that's
pretty definable but how do we do it
with documentaries and there's a well
you could you could make the case with
your film that i mean it it had a
reasonable success i i hope i've got
this right it had reasonable success at
the box office i mean it had enough
success at the box office so it should
have been economically interesting for a
place like netflix or walmart
uh agreed so another
system that's sort of been corrupted
is you used to be able to go on to the
website rotten tomatoes and literally
check the score
of the film
and it's not an exact science but you
your film gets a score and my film gets
a score and here it's pretty good it's a
score and it's pretty good
now if you look at no safe spaces uh the
critics have it
under 50
somewhere 46
and the audience has it at 99
and i would argue
we now must remove the critics from the
equation because
the critics are so left and so woke
that there's nothing you know dennis
prager could make gone with the wind
tomorrow and it would get under 50
on rotten tomatoes so
they've screwed up their own they've
corrupted their own system or sort of
polluted their own system
you must now go with the audience
because there's two scores there's the
critic score and then there's what the
people thought and we now have to throw
out the critics and by the way
it's a two-way street
one of the you know films that would be
an oscar-nominated film that started
starting a young gay black man who was
struggling with his sexuality that'll be
96 with the critics and 65 with the
people well you know that's a testable
hypothesis you could rank order films by
discrepancy between critics and audience
and then rate them according to their
political
uh affiliation and you'd have the answer
right there you could probably you know
a good status tradition could do that in
a day be a very interesting thing to do
because you might be right
in a date
yeah yeah that's right you're right
that's a great point jordan yeah it's
very simple it's very simple it's it's
not only
what the theme of the film is it's does
it have dennis prager's name on it take
a look at the arc of clint eastwood
directed films and watch how they
shrank in the eyes of the critics over
the years since he spoke to the
um famously spoke to the bar the empty
bar stool at the
at the convention i know his film about
the that featured the car and and the
asian family next door which i really
liked i mean that's got slammed for
racism yeah gran torino even by some of
the actors that were in it who i thought
were extremely ungrateful that my
personal opinion i thought that was a
remarkably
non-racist film i mean
eastwood was played a character who was
you know a standard conservative of the
archie bunker type essentially but
as he got to know his neighbors
he placed his allegiance to them over
that of his own family who he saw as
becoming morally corrupt how in the
world that's a racist film is absolutely
beyond me
but jordan i think you're not factoring
in
you're
there's two factors there is what is the
film
and then who directed the film yes yes
yes
if that film was directed by mark
ruffalo there would be no no issues he's
a progressive actor dennis i know you
don't know any actors you pick
the actor that's on you know george
clooney if george clooney directed
gran torino it'd be 15 points higher
percentage points higher with the
critics that's that's my assertion
mm-hmm and i think it'd be fun to do the
statistical analysis maybe somebody
listening could whip that up because a
good graduate student in psychology
could do that very quickly maybe i'll
have my one of my people do that that
would be fun so
why were you motivated you guys to do no
safe spaces and what exactly is it
examining it's examining free speech
which alone i mean first of all uh
everybody involved in it all the
directors the writers the producers were
fantastic people
people i i really admire and uh and
adore
and originally
uh
it was with me and then very early on
they said would you like to do with adam
corolla and uh
i i don't know if your uh viewers are
able to perceive this but we uh we
really do adore each other
and um
uh respect each other and
so the thought of doing this with adam
was uh
i was excited and it turned out that i
had every reason to be excited it's a
great chemistry that we have
just to hear adam describe how different
our backgrounds is is worth the price of
admission
which he does at most of the time when
we go public
adam why don't you give a brief review
of how different our backgrounds are
well
first our similarities were both over
six foot and that's where it ends
uh
dennis is you know a new york he's an
east coast guy i grew up in north
hollywood california dennis's
scholar i was put on academic probation
at a junior college um dennis likes uh
symphonies i like prague rock uh he
likes gefilte fish i like philly cheese
steaks uh
where does it end dennis
uh well what about about the religious
difference
oh yes he's uh a very religious jew i'm
essentially atheist slash pagan
so there's uh again
but you know the thing the thing i
always find about uh
dennis
is an intellectual honesty and a pursuit
of truth
and again he's not interested in
converting people he's interested in
having a dialogue with people and and
i don't know what i don't know what
happened to that process it feels well i
know what happened to it i mean
let's let's examine that for a minute or
two okay so first of all
to have a dialogue you have to assume
there are two people involved at minimum
right dialogue and that there's a logos
involved that there's a logic there that
operates within each individual and
between them
and that they are of the sort
that can be brought to a different
standpoint a different understanding by
the mutual exchange of verbal
information
and so you have to believe that there's
an individual on both sides who has
something unique to contribute and who
can learn as a consequence of rational
negotiation and that that dialogical
process is the means to that and if you
don't believe that there's an individual
you believe that there's group identity
and you don't believe that there's
negotiation and good will in in that
verbal exchange
you only believe there's an exchange of
power there's no dialogue and so that's
why at least normally why the leftists
that you describe the radicals won't
debate with you i mean there's no debate
you see it isn't
the people on the liberals and the
conservatives think that free speech
exists
the radical critics don't it isn't about
whether or not there should be
that free speech should be allowed
it's deeper than that it's whether or
not there is such a thing as free speech
like you know when the when the critical
race theorists and so forth say that
this is a
that they're offering a fundamental
critique of western civilization i think
the idea that it's western as i said is
is somewhat an error but that it's a
fundamental critique they mean that they
mean all the way to the bottom and so
one of the ideas that's being criticized
is the idea of individuals the idea that
we can have dialogue that there is logic
that there is a logos that operates
between people that's all on the table
and
that's why there's no reason for debate
besides you don't have anything to say
adam you're just an expression of your
group
and if you don't know that that's just
your ignorance or perhaps your
malevolence or your self-serving power
something like that i mean this really
is a fundamental critique yeah adam is a
representative of construction workers
that's right i'm a hard hat yeah i
you're right you know i think there is a
circling back to
israel
and the trials and tribulations
i think we sort of make a mistake in in
and we've run into this abroad with a
lot of foreign policy is we assume
they want what we want you know what i
mean like everyone wants to live in
peace everyone wants freedom everyone
wants harmony
and all we have to do
is string together the right words in
the right order and we could express
that to them so we sort of treat it as
if
you're having an argument with your wife
and she just doesn't understand that you
really care about her and love her and
so you will put that down on a greeting
card and we will somehow write this ship
or repair this but if she wants you dead
then what is it that you could say to
her
that would ever remedy that well we
could we could we could modify that
slightly because i think you could say
that it might be the case that
the values that are put forward as
central in the west explicitly
are the most essential human values and
that that's universal but that a
dedicated minority in any place can put
the boots to that pretty damn rapidly
and so you know when when the foreign
policy idea is well there is a desire
for freedom that's part and parcel of
the human spirit fair enough but how
much opposition does that have to run
into before it's impossible and the
answer might be and i think it could
well be that it doesn't have to run into
that much opposition to be in jeopardy
like a committed minority in a committed
small minority can have a
disproportionate effect
i think there's evidence supporting that
proposition i may have
want to comment on
as you did on what uh
what adam said
i was a student at the two institutes at
the school of international affairs in
graduate school at columbia the russian
institute and the middle east institute
i did hebrew arabic and russian so
i want you to know
that adam's analysis of the middle east
was more cogent
than all of my professors in the middle
east institute at columbia
he
hit it
the bullseye
the staggering error of the naive that
everybody wants the same thing
and that's that's why for example uh i
was taught the nonsense and i i talked
about this on fox news two weeks ago and
it sort of went viral
uh that
that the battle in the middle east i
always knew was not about land
if israel were the size of manhattan
they would want to destroy it's not
about land that art no no but every
single professor at columbia said it was
land the new york times says it's land
they all say it's land
you know it i know it and adam knows it
it's that one side wants the other side
dead
that's it and that's because of religion
because for uh for traditional islam
there is no room for jewish or christian
for that matter hegemony in the middle
of the middle east period end of issue
they want israel dead there is nothing
israel israel withdrew from gaza and all
they got was hamas
let me ask you a quick question about
that
do you see any hope i mean israel has
been negotiating somewhat more
successfully with many countries in the
middle east now than say 15 years ago is
that true or not yes in large measure
thanks to the man that is reviled by the
left donald
trump okay so you do think it's true why
would you attribute it to trump because
trump said
i don't give a hoot about the
palestinian radicals they are not the
central issue in the middle east and as
soon as the rest of the arab country saw
that america was strong and not bowing
to the most radical elements of islamic
life they said you know what there's
nothing israel is not all that bad
frankly and we would like to do business
with it
okay so i'm going to ask a meta question
here why do you guys think that that
conflict got dragged into this
conversation i mean the reason i'm
asking that is because in that conflict
everyone in the world their their their
eyes are focused on it in a way that
isn't true of any other conflict and
it's certainly not a consequence of the
number of people who are involved
there's something magical about that
conflict and that pertains to your
statement that it's not about land it's
about religion and maybe it's about even
more than religion who knows or perhaps
not
but you know what what was that what was
you think that called forth that
conflict into this conversation he
raised it when he was talking about the
gulf between liberal and left he gave he
to his credit
raised the middle east as an example
liberals were always pro-israel the left
was always anti-israel
and and and that's
if you can't see the moral clarity of
the middle east issue hamas primitives
versus a modern liberal democracy called
israel there's something wrong with your
moral compass so why do you think the
radical left is pro-palestine
particularly
why did they pick that
i don't know anything about the region
but i do sort of know
what animates people
um my feeling is and as as someone who
grew up with a mother who was sort of
this way
and a grandmother who dabbled in
communism a little bit
um
they
want to push back against everything
that is
so it's it's more of an anarchist
approach than it is here's my plan
and they always no one can really say
that out loud
but it's it's more it's sort of like
defunding so it's part of part of
an revolution and
revolution
it's basically
one house has a well-groomed lawn and a
white picket fence and the other one has
a sofa rotting on the lawn and a guy
smoking weed standing on the porch and i
only have one molotov cocktail
what direction do i throw it it's always
going to go toward the house with the
white picket fence if these people are
lighting them all yeah well one of one
of the things i have noticed about when
in my discussion with well-meaning
people who tilt more to the left say
than you guys
is that
they are genuine generally relatively
unwilling
to consider
the role of dark emotions in political
motivation right they tend to think
things like well the people on the
radical left their hearts in the right
place but they're you know their means
are wrong but what they're trying to do
is to stand up for the oppressed however
badly they're doing it and i think well
i had this experience you can tell me
what you think of this but it really it
really i just re-encountered it i was
looking at the discussion i had with
slavo zizek a few years ago about
marxism punitively that isn't really
what the conversation ended up being
about but i offered a 15-minute critique
of the communist manifesto at the
beginning
and at one point i described it to the
audience as a call to bloody violent
revolution uh which is what it was and
there were a lot of people in the
audience
disproportionate number for my audiences
um who had come to see zizek kicked the
slats out from underneath me and so
there were a lot of people who were very
far left in the audience and when i said
call to bloody violent revolution a good
fifth fifth of the audience cheered and
laughed
and i it stopped me in my tracks because
it was quite chilling you know i heard
the
i heard the mob in that moment
and you know it was a freudian moment
freud noted that people often laughed at
things that had deep psychological
significance and also that you could
express your true feelings when you were
hidden in the crowd well the true
feelings were well
the communist manifesto who the hell
cares about its rationality and its
justification it's like
it's a call for a violent
revolution and ha ha hooray let's do it
and i thought yeah you bastards you
revealed yourself in that laugh and that
chilling awful uh
uh
unconscious willfully blind malevolent
glee at the notion of
the picket fence burning down
and the question is well what's
generating that malevolence and the
surface story is well
you got that through ill-got means
and so we're the right thing to do is to
take it back
and that goes along with the claim that
power is the fundamental motivation what
i can't understand is how the hell those
of us who don't believe that have been
so weak let's say that we allowed the
educational institutions to be overtaken
by people who are propounding that
preposterous doctrine it's like what the
hell's wrong with us conservatives and
liberals alike i don't they know what
did we do wrong
well they know what they're doing in
that
they know everyone's achilles heel
is
a claim of power
especially power that's ill-gotten you
know your dad's rich now you're rich
yeah yeah and then your grandfather was
a landowner right and then race right
so why do you think they weave race into
every single subject it gets the other
side to shut it up
and you don't have to prove your point
you just call everyone a racist and we
can we can well yeah you put them on
your heels right away right because if
you're yelling about systemic racism and
i object to it i'm instantly a racist
it's so convenient but that still
doesn't excuse our weakness in the face
of that now dennis you put your finger
on something you know you said
the thing about conservatives is they
like to be left alone well so maybe that
makes conservatives particularly weak in
the faces right in the face
you see we we have fulfilled lives
outside of power
i am fulfilled uh in so many arenas
having nothing to do with political
power or running the board of education
in my local district i am fulfilled by
my religion i as you heard i'm religious
i am fulfilled i i love america i love
my judaism uh i love my family i love my
friends i i have synagogue every week
one that i i helped found i mean my life
is so rich
not to mention my music
but theirs isn't
their richness derives from political
activism
that is their raison d'etre
and as and as adam pointed out that the
term i use is chaos okay so let me let
me bug you about that for a minute so i
i
have some sympathy with your argument i
think there's empirical data if i
remember correctly showing that the most
unhappy people are left-leaning men
right okay so but we'll leave leave that
to the side really not left-leaning
i think it's a tie
so
i can't remember the data well enough to
cite it with perfect accuracy so but
look
so there's young people they go off to
university and they're looking for this
sense of involvement that you just
described
okay now the
leftist propagandists who are teaching
them let's say are appealing to that and
offering them a kind of romantic
adventure
now
that that matches their developmental
need at that point that should be the
point at which they're richly encultured
by an intact myth something like that
well the fact that that isn't being
provided in a credible manner is what
lays young people open to this kind of
propaganda so it still takes me back to
the failure of liberalism and right
forgive me adam i i for just speaking
again i i just i i just need to say i
have warned about this i began lecturing
at the age of 21 i have a very odd life
and i remember telling audiences in my
20s
you
speaking to the my parents generation
the world war ii generation
you your motto was let's give the next
generation everything we didn't have
and specifically material a wealth of
education and and
and peace
and uh the problem is you didn't give us
what you did have
i knew this in my 20s
the my parents did give it to me it's
not my parents but the the world war ii
generation did not give their children
americanism or christianity in any
coherent manner and we are living the
consequences
okay so so justify that why why would
you point to christianity
for example dominant look i'm a jew but
it's a dominant religion of the west and
certainly of the united states if
christianity look christianity failed in
europe and we got nazism fascism and
communism what's going to happen in
america when christianity fails yeah
well you know i've been talking to some
of the people associated with the
rational atheist movement and
what i'm seeing there is some
realization that whatever comes up to
replace the religion that they decried
is going to be a hell of a lot worse
than the religion that they decried
that's right and that it makes me think
too you know
go ahead and what we get is wearing mass
outdoors and copious amounts of hand
sanitizing
uh even when it's unnecessary i mean
that is right
covert has taught us that this is the
new religion it transcends science
in in many cases
uh guys i've got to jump off because i
have to begin my podcast but um
i thank you so much for having me jordan
you had to make a pleasure talking to
you and i i hope we can have you on my
show is uh sooner than later because i
always enjoy speaking to you and i'll
leave it in the very capable hands of
dennis prager now i'd i'd like that so
let's arrange that okay i'd like to do
that okay okay
adam all right thanks adam thanks
so let's go down the religious route a
little bit and we still you know we
still haven't talked about that the
censorship that no safe spaces has faced
i mean we touched on it a little bit
with netflix and walmart
well well that's the that's the dominant
arena and obviously it's completely uh
it's completely ignored by the
mainstream media which review nonsense
and this is not a nonsense film look i
th the most important answer to all of
this is
for your copious number of viewers to
actually watch it it's available online
at so many vehicles no safe spaces just
you know salem now i know my syndicator
has it salemnow.com or
nosafespaces.com or
it's easy to find uh
we
have to
there are conservative films that i
watch
uh out of out of duty
uh this one is not out of duty this is
out out of uh
out of pleasure it it it is
it is quite powerful so the the the only
answer is to succeed without them
but that what they have done to the film
uh is not economically uh or certainly
not morally justifiable
and uh it gives you an idea although i i
think you you have an idea
of what of what we're living through uh
today
well it's funny that a free movie about
free speech is having a hard time
in fact you could probably you could
hardly hope for a better outcome in some
very you know uh
perverse sense um
just out of curiosity have you just
what what would happen if you just
placed it on youtube
what would happen if we just that's an
interesting i don't know the answer i
would have to ask the the producers i i
i only know the content more than more
than that uh you mean just free just
free free well it wouldn't just be free
because you could monetize it through
ads now that's not a tremendous way of
generating revenue but it might be a way
of it would also be interesting to see
what would happen well look the truth is
i mean they have to
they're very honorable these guys i
haven't gotten a penny just for the
record i didn't do this for money to
begin with i would have been happy to
make money i'm not anti-money but i
didn't do it for money i did it because
i believe
so strongly in the message and the
greatness of the film uh but the their
first thing
was to repay the people who did invest
in the film and and that's uh
that's one economic constraint that
can't be shaken so easily that's right
it was an expensive it as people will
see it is really well done
but uh
we're living uh uh i mean jordan we're
just living in in
in a different world
i'll give you a great example you'll
find this fascinating i was on bill
maher's program uh i know you've been i
was on uh a year and a half ago right
before the lockdowns i never say by the
way covert i always say lockdown
uh and uh i was on on it october
actually the lockdowns began in february
or march so uh
he was talking about how much donald
trump lies and i and i said you know
as much as you think he lies it doesn't
compare to left-wing lies says really
like what and this is by the way you
could see this anyone could see this on
youtube
uh
of my appearance on on his show so
uh i said well for example that
america's systemically racist that is
one of the greatest lies in the history
of the world in fact in my view i think
it's not a lie i think it's an
anti-truth
because lies just slip by
right an anti-truth is a lie that's so
egregious that it's the opposite of
what's true i love it i will cite you
and i will always cite you i will never
claim that i made it made up that term
that's great so in fact you were like
that what i have said and written
uh i i taught jewish history at brooklyn
college and i've written books on jewish
history uh so i
uh i have said that this is the greatest
national lie libel
since the bloodline
the medieval blood libel for those of
your viewers who don't know is
uh when christians accused jews the
middle ages of killing christian
children to use their blood to bake
matzah for passover
which was equally evil and absurd
massive numbers of jews were tortured to
death as a result and the entire all of
the jews of england were expelled
from the whole country as a result of
that libel the second greatest national
libel
in my opinion is that america is
systemically racist
america is the greatest attempt at
non-racial
uh multi-ethnic multi-racial country in
the history of the world
and
one of them but you don't deny the
existence of racism or prejudice
obviously okay so why why do you have
such trouble with the term systemic
because systemic is is sort of like when
barack obama said it's in the dna
system right means that the system is
geared to hurting blacks the system is
not right so it's the central tendency
the claim is systemic means central
tendency yes exactly it's built in it's
it's just that that's an anti-truth to
use your term
so
okay so let me ask you a question from
the side here for a sec okay i was
looking at your work on the torah i've
been thinking about this idea so the
idea of systemic racism is the idea that
the central animating principle of the
united states is prejudicial and racist
to the point of of enslavement that's
the claim and it's it's an it's an
analog of the claim that power is the
fundamental motivation for
human interaction
at least at least under capitalist
conditions let's say but i think it's
even deeper than that and so now you've
studied the torah in depths and i've
i've been thinking
and you also claim that the torah was
was is the word of god
i've got that right yes
okay now is the ultimate author yes okay
so i'm thinking of the the bible is
actually a set of stories that was told
across a very long period of time and
they were looped together for for
reasons that we don't exactly understand
i'm not speaking as a religious person
here precisely but there's a there's a
voice there that's part of the central
tendency of civilization
and that's and it's not a voice that
speaks of power that's right
okay what does it speak of
as far as you're concerned good and evil
it's it speaks about
a just god who wants us to be good it is
it's it's almost to the point of
sounding corny
every every profound truth is corny you
know i mean oh that's dull i'll live
with that that's right
that's what that's why okay so what does
good what does what is the good that's
represented in that book how would you
define it because you wouldn't define it
as power seeking
no of course not in fact it's it's
almost anti-power
uh
remember if i know you know this but god
did not want the israelites to have a
king
that ironically that was the gift of
theocracy
i'm not for theocracy in the modern age
but
to be intellectually honest the idea
that god is the ruler means that no man
is the ruler
yes well that's that's a very
interesting freedom and less power well
that's a very interesting issue too
because i've been thinking a lot about
that psychologically is that one of the
advantages to
parsing off the idea of ultimate
sovereignty into an abstract domain
which is what a religious claim does
especially when it's attributed to a god
that's even outside of nature is that
the central core of sovereignty can no
longer ever be identified with a single
individual that's right but we have no
idea how nasa i've been thinking about
the analogy there with uh with a
parliamentary or with a with a
constitutional monarchy you know because
the queen of canada the queen of england
etc she bears a tremendous amount of
symbolic weight
and your president also bears that
weight and that's actually
a problem with the system i think
because
because the president has to bear the
symbolic weight there's a tendency for
him to become elevated beyond other
mortals i mean you saw that sort of
thing happening in rome with the
deification of the
of the emperors and if you it seems to
me if you don't parse off the idea of
ultimate sovereignty into an abstract
domain you risk confusing it with
proximal leaders or perhaps proximal
ideas
well
you don't you you know me somewhat but
you i don't expect you to know me well
and i can just tell you i have often
said on my radio show
which is now more than 35 years
that the overriding message of all 35
years has been to teach people the
consequences of secularism
the the deleterious consequences of
secularism secularism is good for
government and it stinks for everything
else
and what you just raised was one of an
not infinite but an extremely large
number of examples
we are living now through leftism is a
product of secularism
and uh there was moral chaos
dostoyevsky was right i mean it's just a
fact you know where there is no god all
is permitted
we are we are living through it now when
you have
tens of thousands of medical people
saying that if you if you demonstrate
against racism it's healthy
after telling us to wear masks when we
walk with our dog outdoors
i mean the corruption of every of every
institution in the society has resulted
when there is no god there is not only
no good and evil but there is no math
that even i didn't predict the oregon
education department has announced there
will no longer be only one right answer
in math did you did you know that about
that jordan i've seen that sort of thing
you know percolating i didn't know it
had become yes it is specific all the
roed oregon education department has
announced this that that is the policy
here from here to four or not here to
four from here on
yeah you know there's a reason that
christ was a carpenter you know
he got his measurements right
uh-huh
that's cute
yeah well it's more than cute right
because to build a house you have to
tell the truth otherwise it falls down
and you need to build it on a firm
foundation also well we don't have the
foundation is being eroded oh yeah so i
was telling you about the bill maher
show so uh he he said so
uh he said all the lies the lies the
lies i said doesn't compare to the
left-wing lies that amer that's when we
got sidetracked which is
on on america being systemically racist
and i'll tell you i'll tell you another
one bill
uh that uh men menstruate
and you've got to watch this it's
actually as i said it's on youtube
and he started laughing at me and so did
the whole audience
that i would make up something so
preposterous and ascribe it to the left
this is october
of 2019
that
leftists his audience and he were
laughing at the idea that anybody would
say men menstruate now if you deny men
menstruate you are a hater and you will
be removed from public life
i have another question for you about
your religious writing i'm going to talk
to a number of islamic intellectuals in
the next
month
it's something i've been thinking about
doing for a long time but i've been
hesitant too for a variety of reasons
not least my ignorance of islam
you
write about the torah as the revealed
word of god
and so
you know
i have a tremendous amount of respect
for biblical writings and i've done my
best to approach them in a humble and
open attitude trying to understand
what's there assuming that there is
something there or the stories wouldn't
have lasted as long as they have lasted
and guided the development of our entire
civilization
but there are plenty of claims to reveal
truth and so
there's obviously tension and conflict
between islam and christianity and
judaism and they're all predicated on
the idea of revealed truth
and
i mean when you make a claim for
revealed truth how do you distinguish it
from other claims of revealed truth and
or how do you adjudicate between the
claims because the way we adjudicate
between the claims is through war
and that that's not
all that helpful at all in time you
would adjudicate in this regard i think
you would adjudicate
uh using uh using common sense you would
uh by their fruit you you shall know uh
that that's from the new testament and i
i'm a big a fan of that the phrase and
that verse
uh so
the torah and and i and i do isolate the
first five books as is the traditional
jewish view is that those are primus
enter paris they're the first among
equals
and
uh that is what gave us everything let's
put it this way no torah
uh no bible no christianity no islam
so
in a sense i got a i got a better case
for the torah's divinity than anything
else because everything else is
predicated on the divinity of the torah
okay so then you you make a case in some
sense i would say an implicit case that
anti-semitism for example is a marker of
deviation from the path of the torah but
the path that runs what from the torah
through christianity and through islam
as well
i mean because your point is it's it's
the fundamental text out of which these
other
other systems grew
anti-semitism is ultimately the hatred
of the jews for bringing a judging god
into the world people don't want to be
judged
well that's understandable you know that
people although the problem is is if you
dispense with judgment you also dispense
with value and you dispense with it
right it's a big problem
yeah it's a big problem it is i've been
very i tell my christian friends and you
don't get a more pro-christian
non-christian than me in in contemporary
life but i
i tell them you you blew it with just
talking about god as love
it's it's not yeah well you know carl
jung said something interesting about
that you know because the christ that's
presented in the gospels is a figure i
suppose particularly characterized for
his mercy
but in the book of revelation
he comes back as a judge
and virtually everyone fails the
judgment and jung's comment was
any ideal is a judge
and so if you don't tell the whole story
of the so the question is do we need
ideals and you know i would say to some
degree
part of the critique of the radical left
is that ideals themselves are
discriminatory and there's actually
truth in that that ideals are
discriminatory
the question is whether they're
arbitrarily discriminatory and
if you say yes then well what do you
strive for and i guess the answer is for
everyone to be equal
all right so that's so that's their
discriminatory ideal
it means it discriminates against
excellence
listen uh the same crackpot the head of
the classical music at the new york
times made a list this is years and you
this is like 20 15 years ago
and and uh
only because i follow music do i even
know this he made a list of the 10
greatest composers and he didn't have uh
he didn't have handle in it the who of
course composed the messiah he didn't
have haydn in it the father of the
symphony and the string quartet
and he didn't have schubert in it and he
said oh well you know why he said but he
did have bartok uh in it and he had
debussy in it who were fine but they're
not in the top ten uh i don't think
anybody could rationally argue that they
are uh but in any event uh he said why
he said i i just can't have that many
austrian germans on the list
so it wasn't the list of the best
composers
that's what
all of this is and it's anti-standards
that's well look there's an attack on a
meritocracy on the idea of meritocracy
right so i mean i've wondered well is
that actually an attack on the idea of
merit and i would say yes it is in fact
attack on the idea of merit i never
really
look you know you said something it was
a throwaway line you caught me on one of
mine and i'll catch you in one of yours
that anti-semitism is rooted in people's
irritation at the idea of a judgmental
god being brought into existence i mean
that that's a hell of a claim so i mean
it do you do you believe that that that
that is the fundamental explanation
yes uh there are a lot of non-jewish uh
uh analysts edward flannery a major
catholic writer and ernest vondenheig
one of the greatest clearest thinkers of
of the last century uh they they wrote
about this the jews introduced
uh uh this god into history and they've
never been forgiven for it also uh
this i'll tell you another reason for
anti-semitism is is
people believe the jews are chosen
see this is a very everybody
acknowledges that jewish chosenness is a
reason for anti-semitism however as i
pointed out jews are
two tenths of one percent of the world
who gives a damn if two-tenths of one
percent of the world thinks they're
chosen the chinese think they're the
center of the world well chosen chosen
and successful might be
thank you that's correct that's exactly
right so deep down people don't laugh
when jews say they're chosen they don't
believe that japan gets the sun before
the rest of humanity even though they
are the land of the rising sun and as
the sun is on their flag but nobody
cares if the japanese think they get the
son first but they do care if the jews
think they're chosen
so there's been a tremendous amount of
resentment of of the fact that maybe
they are but of course chosen never
meant better never
by the way one other thing that this is
yeah well you've got to ask yourself do
you really want to be chosen by god
well as tevye in in uh fiddler on the
roof said wanted to choose somebody else
once
yeah yeah those have not benefited from
chosen this uh
give it given well you know you might
say they benefited and and suffered
disproportionately all right that's fair
yes
yeah and i don't know for sure if that's
a fate that people would choose if they
had the option that is exactly correct
then
okay so let's go back to this revelation
thing because i'm i'm i'm gonna have
these discussions and i need some
guidance and so we we've got now you
made a claim you know that the torah is
the source of these of christianity and
islam and judaism obviously as well and
so because it's the source
well then what
what should be the attitude of other
people of the book towards
jews and towards the torah
uh among christians there's a
schizophrenic view
uh
for for many in the church and until
moderate the modern period the jews were
a living rebuke uh as one uh i don't
remember which christian thinker said
that the the jews crucify christ ev in
every generation just by their continued
existence
uh so
there's been
there's been an animosity in christian
christendom
because the jews rejected their own
jesus was jewish the apostles were
jewish the claims were made on the basis
of the jewish people do you do you think
that's distinct from a sort of intrinsic
tribalism do you think there's more to
it than i mean we're tribal in in in a
very deep sense
this this transcended tribalism because
uh it certainly wasn't ethnic
uh it was ideological it was theological
the the jew jesus comes to the jews and
the very people that he came to are the
ones who said he's not he's not god and
he's not messiah so this this was this
this created a fair amount of resentment
uh
american christians were an anomaly and
and i loved them for it american
christians said they were the second
chosen people the jews were the first
and we americans are the second on which
i believe by the way uh okay so let me
ask you another question this is some
one this is a horrible question and i've
been dying to to think it through for a
long time
so
there's a line of christian thinking i
would say
and and northrop frye i think a canadian
critic who wrote some great books on the
bible you might be familiar with fry he
wrote words with power and there's a
second volume
which i can't bring to mind at the
moment but
he thought about the the torah as the
the story of the sequential rise and
failure of the state
and that the new testament was
a consequence of the emergence of the
idea that salvation was to be found
through the individual and not through
the state
and that seemed to me to be uh parallel
with the tension in the old testament
between
the prof between dogma and the prophets
so so
is it is it the case
is there a difference between in between
judaism and christianity with regards to
the degree to which the state as seen as
a as the primary mode of redemption
and is that tangled up with the conflict
in israel
well there are a lot of issues that that
are tangled in one first of all you
should know that salvation plays a
minimal role in judaism
and and i know biblical hebrew very well
and i cannot think of even the term
salvation
uh second it seems to be more like the
promised land
well judaism is earthbound
there's a belief a tremendous belief in
the afterlife but it plays minimal role
in the torah
because as soon as you start focusing on
the afterlife the fear is that you won't
focus on this life
and and judaism is extremely this life
focused
secondly this is a very important point
it is actually
my biggest single reason for my
adoration of the torah and judaism
it's the only religion that divides the
world
between good and evil and not between
believer and non-believer
so right right so that's that's that
seems to me from a psychological
perspective as a as a move towards a
further abstraction
well it's not a psychological issue it's
a moral issue
that's fine in our view god does not
divide the world between jew and non-jew
or believer and non-believer but between
good people and bad people
the
god
sends good
good non-jews to heaven and bad jews to
hell
that's why jews uh jews welcome converts
but never sought them because you don't
have to be a jew to be saved
but you do have to be a muslim and you
do have to be a christian
okay so okay so so that's one that's one
example of i think that's one example of
of the operation of the idea of
salvation the implicit idea of salvation
anyways that there's a reward for proper
moral behavior at the individual level
that's right okay what about my way to
heaven okay what do you think about my
other proposition is that one of the
things that distinguishes christianity
from judaism is the relative role the
relative importance of the role of the
state now you describe judaism as
earthbound and i actually think that's
one of its great advantages because
judaism does celebrate life in a quite
in a rich and quite remarkable way and
and and glorifies earthly life and and
there's certainly strains of
christianity where that wasn't the case
at all
but then
there is this emphasis there seems to be
a continued emphasis on the idea of the
land and the state and and then i said
there's fry's notion that you know the
torah is a sequential story of the rise
and failure of the state as as the
entity of salvation or redemption and
then the emergence of the ideal it's
foreshadowed in some sense by the
prophetic tradition and you know
christians read that of course as christ
being first and foremost among the
prophets i mean obviously also the son
of god but a continuation of that
prophetic tradition but the
transformation seems to be something
like
a more radical or explicit emphasis on
the individual as the local of the
redemptive battle
i mean i might be wrong about this get
that's why i'm asking the state this
there is no state uh so to speak there
is the there are the prophets
and there are the priests that that's
where power resided one had moral power
one had one had uh
cult power if you occultic i don't mean
called in a bad sense but
the cultic concept
and and that that was pretty much it
that's why as i said the
the the king arose against god's wishes
so it's it's not exactly a big
state-centered religion if you don't
even want a king
uh you there you know moses says that
you shall appoint the policemen and uh
and judges
uh in in exodus that's a that's
important you have to have a
it is judaism is not state centered it's
law centered
that's the issue all right well let's
look at exodus though i mean and
so
exodus
moses leads the jews out of tyranny and
then into this interregnum which is a
very interesting uh development i think
because
the
escape from tyranny isn't followed by
redemption or salvation it's followed by
an even more chaotic state that's even
more dismal in some sense which i think
is unbelievably brilliant right because
we tend to think
a state of tyranny will dissolve and
everything will be happy as a
consequence but the exodus story says no
no matter how bad the tyranny there's
going to be an interregnum in the desert
where everyone loses faith
and then there's a journey toward the
promised land so that structures the
narrative and it's the promised it's the
it's this idea of the promised land that
that well that i'm trying to focus on
and understand i mean you you
characterize judaism just now as as as
law
partly law and partly the the cultic
tradition the priestly tradition but
there is this i mean the story of exodus
as you well know is an absolutely
central biblical narrative and it's a
stunningly powerful story but it does
involve
it frames life as a journey towards the
promised land and that in that story
that being an actual land
and it seems to me that part of the
christian transformation i do think it
has its roots in the jewish prophetic
tradition is this change in emphasis i
mean i was convinced by fry's arguments
which weren't anti-semitic by the way in
any great old scene
they don't sound it to me at all like
that
it's not a way in which jews understood
themselves let me put it to you that way
the promised land is where
the the law will be
put to use and
a holy land with a holy people
this will be god's locus
i view the jews as god's third attempt
at making a good world the first was
conscience that didn't work the second
was noah and giving him basic laws that
didn't work and then picking a people
and giving them the role to be a model
and uh that hasn't worked out too well
either
listen uh i would love to continue can
you give me five minute break and i will
continue absolutely okay fine all right
[Music]
so um
i wanted to ask you further so i'm
hosting these discussions as i mentioned
with a more liberal muslim scholar and a
more conservative muslim scholar and i'm
woefully unprepared for it because what
the hell do i know but it seems to me
that
to whatever degree it's possible that
all of branches might be offered when
they can be
and so
that's partly why i was curious about
the
this issue of revealed truth i mean what
do we do when we have complete competing
claims to revealed truth
and and
apart from war because war in some sense
is about axioms that can't be given up
and and with that war is just not an
option for us in a sense not an option
like it was because the con the
possibility of a gated cap i have
thought about this a great deal so i
have a i have a quick answer but it's it
took me decades to develop
and that is
my criterion
is not is your religion true or mine
true
uh
my criterion
i have two one is what type of people do
you produce
uh nothing else interests me
uh if if atheists produced
uh
kind and wise people i would give
atheism much more seriousness than i now
do
uh
but the so my my
criterion is one
what type of people do you produce
and two
do you bring people to the the god
of the ten commandments
that's it
if your religion affirms that god gave
the ten commandments
uh i am a fan of your religion
if your religion does not affirm that
then it may be beautiful
i have i don't disqualify that
possibility
but it is not it is not divine
revelation
given that
remember when we say divine we're
talking about the god the jews
introduced to the world you can't hijack
our term and so you can make up your own
god but
the god
that was brought into the world is the
god of the old testament specifically
the god of the torah specifically the
god of creation exodus and ten
commandments
if you affirm those then you are a
kindred religion to mine and have an
essential truth to it i don't believe in
jesus christ but i do believe that
christians who bring the world to the
god of the torah and the to the ten
commandments
are he doing god's work
so okay so then that that begs a broader
question i mean we're not currently
there's no current major religious
dispute that's worldwide between
christians and buddhists let's say
and so where does that leave
non-where does that leave religious
believers who who aren't allied with the
central book of the west broadly
speaking
i don't have an issue uh remember since
i believe god judges people by their
ethics uh i don't care if you're
buddhist
if you're if buddhism is created in you
a good person
and and giving you wisdom i see so
you're using adherence to the to the ten
commandments
as a as a as an explicit description of
what constitutes ethical good
essentially yes it is but i admit i i
fully acknowledge buddhists are not
teaching the ten commandments as such i
i understand that certainly you know not
a sabbath day
by the way not all christians are
teaching the sabbath day either uh 50 of
the of the
catholic priests and protestant
ministers i've i've asked do you believe
christians are duty-bound to the observe
the sabbath have said no
so what do you think about christ was
asked in in this is outlined in the new
testament which of the commandments he
thought was
first and foremost
which is an interesting question right
because it presumes it posits that
there's a central ethic that manifests
itself across the ten rules that's still
implicit
and christ had an answer to that right
love god
yes which is you know quite an answer
and what was the what was the comment
and no one dared ask him any more
questions after that which i think is
quite comical um and and it's one of
those little markers that makes you
think that something was really going on
um it's because the story is so
interesting but i mean in in in in
buddhism
is there an implicit array of is there
an implicit ethic that matches the ethic
that's implicit in the in the ten
commandments and of course there are
many more commandments than ten i happen
to have studied buddhism in england
under a buddhist professor trevor ling
and my take and i'm not an expert in any
way but i have some understanding i
think of buddhism
this is not its
question
its question
is ultimately
uh how to avoid suffering
uh
in this world and uh to
reach
uh
the light or or whatever nirvana would
be uh would be translated
whichever term you use sanskrit or
otherwise
so for example
uh
he said and by the way it changed my
life uh
when he said it in class it was in
england
he said
uh the
buddhism teaches that all pain in life
comes from
what is it desires and expectations
that are not fulfilled
or even not not not fulfilled just from
desires and expectations
it changed my life because from that day
to this and i've written a book on
happiness and i wrote a chapter on this
i have no expectations and it is one of
the reasons i'm happy
everything therefore if i wake up
tomorrow without an aneurysm i think i'm
the luckiest guy in the world so uh i
adopted the do you think that's
equivalent in some sense to like
subverting your will to the will of god
is that the same idea no no no nothing
to do with god zero to do with god
as far as i'm concerned pure luck if i'm
hit by a a drunk driver tomorrow
uh or not is it sorry sorry that is
sorry that isn't what i meant and as i
must have phrased the question
improperly
is the id the buddhist idea
that desire expectation is the cause of
suffering is that analogous to the idea
that
in judaism and christianity that people
give up their own egotistical will and
follow the will of god
it's a it's an interesting uh read
i i don't know because
let's see uh
i'll tell you why at least for judaism i
can't speak for christians
in
and this was the second part which i
rejected i accepted dropping
expectations it was it was to me
brilliant
i utterly rejected dropping desires
i desire a family i desire a cure for
cancer i the
the list of desires i have is endless
and and certainly judaism would never
want me to drop desires
well in buddha i mean buddha reached
nirvana but then in some sense came back
to bring the population along with him i
mean he had desires so i wonder if it's
more a matter of like desires that are
ego predicated or desires that are an
expression of arbitrary power let's say
well that's a great question to ask a
buddhist i i will tell you this i had a
i did
i was blessed my first 10 years of radio
one of my shows was
was as the moderator of a of three
clergy uh a priest minister rabbi
different ones each week and after five
years i did it for ten years i invited
buddhists and muslims and mormons and
every religion on earth i asked a
buddhist one night
so it do
i want to understand if i have
a correct read
of
of buddhism and its ideal
he was a monk so i knew i couldn't ask
him about a wife or children but so i
said
if your brother died
would the ideal buddhist
response be no sadness
and he said that is correct
the ideal buddhist response would be
things live and things die
and that
that detachment yes and then that begs
the question well do you remain inactive
in the face of suffering
and you would seem to me that
that you do
right but then that begs the question of
why buddha didn't just stay in nirvana
when he had the opportunity
it's an excellent question
so
listen uh uh i'm uh i'm i'm okay with
inconsistency yeah yeah look fair enough
and we're not gonna iron all this out
but so let's if you don't mind maybe we
could go back to this islamic issue so
um what do you see as a pathway
i know you don't know the answer to this
but no one does but you thought about
these things a lot and you know you're a
profoundly religious person and
like
what's the proper attitude
towards peace
if i'm having a dialogue with these
islamic scholars i mean i have lots of
people who view my
youtube videos and read my books in the
islamic world
and i'm happy about that i'm pleased
about that and you know many of them
were annoyed for example when i talked
to ayan herzeali
and they said well you should talk to
some other muslims i thought well i know
that and so i've decided to go ahead and
do that
i mean what what
what needs to change do you think
within each of us perhaps in order for
these the conflict that keeps raging
centered in the middle east to start to
moderate itself
how do we open the door to that i gave
my answer earlier the the the day
look
here's here's a rhetorical question
if the israelis announced we are
disarming no more army no more weapons
uh what would happen the next day and if
the palestinians said
we are disarming no more fighting no
more terror no more rockets nothing what
would happen the next day in the first
case there would be the genocide of the
jews of israel in the second case there
would be peace
uh so why don't you ask that question of
these people uh uh that what would
happen if if both sides announced that
they are completely disarming what would
happen the next day uh uh do do they
really believe that there was genocide
against the palestinians i think there
were eight times as many palestinians
today as when israel was founded this is
the worst attempted genocide in the
history of genocide i mean it is it is
as ludicrous as it is evil to charge
israel with genocide uh uh it would be
the first time in history as i said at
my my oxford union debate on this very
issue of hamas in israel
i i said it'd be the first time in
history that in in a battle between a uh
a dictatorship or a tyranny and a free
state the free state was the one that
wanted war
and and the tyranny wanted peace i mean
we're expected to to believe nonsense
uh and and i i'm so do you believe do
you believe that this is
baked into
this islamic faith yes if so yes and
i'll yes i think it is uh okay so what
is it that's baked in i'll tell you i've
been called in the greatest arab writer
who ever lived i think was the 14th
century uh in the
ma the introduction to history
he he wrote
and he is again he's considered the
greatest writer not only the greatest
arab writer in history according to aj
always is the great uh
ajp taylor the great the british
historian he was the greatest historian
who ever lived and that was uh that was
taylor's uh that take that's a little
romantic but it doesn't matter he's got
a great reputation
and he wrote in in the mukha
the the introduction to history
that unlike jews and christians
the superiority of islam can be seen in
the fact that they were prepared to kill
people to convert
that's baked in
well so then where where exactly does
this leave us let's say on the road to
peace so if i said i'm going to talk to
these guys and i don't know what'll come
out of that
uh maybe we could have a conversation
with you and them
i would love it
i've dialogued with muslims i know i
know i'm not a question
and and
listen the bigger question to me is not
is it baked in is it is islam reformable
uh and uh th this uh lord was it the
lord acton no no another another uh may
been lord acton uh the british viceroy
in egypt in the 19th century said islam
reformed is islam no longer
that's see that's not true with
christianity which obviously did go
through a reformation
and uh state state christian although i
don't know if catholics would fully
agree with that but
nevertheless
uh
that yes well but we don't we also don't
know if that meant the dissolution of
christianity over the long run that's
correct
that that is that is a very fair
question
uh
uh i i don't have an answer i i
it may well be that the christian that
christianity really does survive it will
be african christians who make it
possible
well or you know or chinese christians
since it's growing faster there is an
ancient rome yes it's very peculiar so
who knows right but all right well look
dennis i think that's a probably a
reasonable place to stop
um i just can i just make a plug for uh
two things no safe spaces
the movie that we began with and my
rational bible
which is written uh with atheists in
mind as i write it it is complete it is
a use of reason to explain
the five books of the torah the first
five books of the bible and uh
deuteronomy the third volume is coming
out
this year but genesis and exodus are out
and uh maybe we could maybe we could
have a discussion at some point just
about exodus i would like that that uh
that would be nirvana to me
all right well let's schedule it in and
we'll do that because i i need the
preparation i like i said i want to do a
lecture series on exodus in the fall
right so
all right well anything else dennis
people should only know how much uh i
admire you i i know you're you're
self-conscious about that you don't have
to say a word
but uh
i cite you often
uh as one of the the the handful of
truth and goodness seekers i know
thank you
that's a that's a weak thank you for
that compliment so much appreciated
it's right thank you until we meet again
thanks again be well all right
[Music]
you